we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day
here is a call i got about a double
standard that a viewer has identified
let's take a listen to it hey David why
is it that when there's two FBI agents
who exchanged text messages with each
other that reveal they might be anti
strong to have an anti sharp bias they
immediately get fired right but whenever
the current Attorney General who is the
boss of Robert Mahler has as a private
citizen made comments where he would
intentionally obstruct justice and that
doesn't matter what's why is that what's
the host Karan I like that double
standard just a thought yeah this is a
great question you are referring of
course to Peter struck who was involved
in some anti-trump text messages he was
involved in Robert molars investigative
team as soon as it came to light that
that took place he was removed even
though there was not actually evidence
that his personal politics influenced
how he carried out that investigation in
any way but trumpets were calling for
his head meanwhile Jeff Sessions is
pushed out because he's refused on the
Russia investigation in comes Matthew
Whitaker whose public statements in both
audio visual form and in writing in op
eds about the Moller investigation have
been made clear he thinks it's out an
overreach he thinks it shouldn't be
going on and he actually has ideas as to
exactly how he would try to stop it that
all comes out and we say logically this
guy really shouldn't be the supervisor
of that investigation and the trumpets
and Whitaker himself say well listen I
made those comments when I was merely a
public person when I was merely a
private citizen rather and it doesn't
influence how I am going to manage and
supervise that investigation now they
would never accept that if the parties
were reversed and they literally did not
accept it when it came to a low-level
Moeller staffer in Peter struck but
somehow it's okay when it's Matthew
Whitaker but you know what they don't
care
hypocrisy and double standards don't
matter any
and that's why we've got to vote them
out in 2020 there's no other way forward
they must be voted out in 2020 we've got
a great bonus show for you today become
a member become a patron to access it
I'll speak to you then or otherwise on
tomorrow's program